dans cette demande je reprend
l'intégralité des éléments qui existe
dans son dossier d'instruction depuis
des mois dans cette demande je réitère
une première demande que j'avais fait en
octobre 2017 sur la désignation d'un
administrateur ad-hoc pour cette petite
fille et pour sa soeur administrateurs
haddock c'est une personne extérieure à
la famille qui a la charge de protéger
les intérêts de cet enfant de lui
désigner un avocat autre que l'avocat
des parents pour permettre à cette
petite fille de prendre toute sa place
de parole ainsi qu'à sa soeur tous les
éléments sont là les analyses je devrais
même pas avoir analysé ce dossier je ne
devrais même pas à fournir plus de 20
pages de conclusions à un juge
d'instruction c'est sous le travail
à la base ce n'est pas le mien or
aujourd'hui je le fais mon confrère le
fait nous n'arrêtons de multiplier les
courriers des analyses dans ce dossier
donc là il ya une volonté manifeste de
ne pas les lire de ne pas les entendre
et là ça m'interroge sauf que nous avons
une petite fille qui potentiellement si
ce n'est sûrement continuer à être
agressés à être maltraité et si un jour
un drame surgit là il y aura des
responsabilités à aller chercher et les
magistrats ne sont pas exemptes de ses
responsabilités il ya un véritable déni
dans ce dossier une mise en danger
volontaire
j'estime de la part de sujets
instructions de cette petite fille qui
est maintenu dans un milieu familial qui
me semblent toxiques et l'administrateur
haddock il est grand temps qu'il
intervienne avec un avocat de son choix
pour pouvoir faire toutes les demandes
nécessaires pour préserver l'intégrité
l'intégralité de sa petite fille si le
silence devait être un nouveau gardé par
le juge d'instruction sur cette demande
actes j'aurai la capacité et julie dray
de saisir la chambre de l'instruction
d'un appel et devant la chambre
d'instruction je demanderai à ce que le
juge d'instruction soit dessaisie de ce
dossier que le président de la chambre
d'instruction sur le réserve comme
c'est à dire qu'ils le gardent
instruisent lui même le dossier et je
ferai tout mais demandent désormais
entre les mains du président de la
chambre de l'instruction